[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi,
Timothy Jordan here.
Your friendly developer
advocate, taking you
around Google I/O 2017.
We're now in the maps
and mobile web tent
and I'm here with
Chris Wilson, who's
going to show us how
Lighthouse works.
CHRIS WILSON: All right.
Thank you, Timothy.
So Lighthouse is
a tool that we've
created to help build
really good web experiences,
help you improve
web experiences.
I'm going to actually
enter in a URL right here.
This is the media
player application
that we showed off in the
Web State of the Union talk.
We also have a talk
about it tomorrow,
in the future of
audio and video.
And it's going to
run a series of tests
here to test a bunch
of different things
about whether it has a manifest,
whether it has a service
worker installed, if it's going
to work when it's offline,
how it works in different
network environments, all kinds
of stuff.
How long it takes for the user
to get an interactive access
to the page, all
that kind of stuff.
And something went
hideously wrong.
So let's take a
look at the report.
So this is kind of
cheating, because
this particular
application gets 100%.
It does super well, right?
I mean, we hand-coded this.
Paul Lewis is an expert--
he knows what he's doing.
Like, he has a manifest on
here, it's got a service worker,
it works offline.
You know, there's still
things to be done.
Like performance--
you can always
try to do better at performance.
A little bit-- a tiny
bit in accessibility.
We could do, maybe
some best practices,
and passive listeners--
that kind of stuff.
A really awesome score, right?
I had to use this site because
all of mine are horribly bad.
Everything.
You know, I know what the
lowest score I've seen today is.
It's my own site, so.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well I would say
I'm not going to tell anybody,
but you just told everybody.
So now-- this is a social
contract to fix that.
CHRIS WILSON: It's
all open source,
so you could go fix my site.
Maybe?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I don't
think that's going to happen.
Chris, thanks so much.
CHRIS WILSON: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This
is Paul, and Paul's
going to tell us a little bit
about what's going on with AMP.
And I have a fancy
question to ask.
PAUL: Then ask your
fancy question.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
My fancy question
is the overlap
between AMP and PWA.
When are we going to see it,
and how well does it work?
PAUL: Yeah, there's a good
reason why we're so close
together here with the stalls.
And I just talked
about it this morning--
how to combine those two in
a really, really nice way.
And there's-- there are three
development models that really
work well.
Because what we're saying is
that you want to start fast
and you want to stay fast.
So you can either build an
AMP that is both a PWA--
you can actually do that.
But you also lead from an
AMP to a progressive web app,
and use your AMP
content as a data source
in that progressive web app.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
So that makes a lot of sense.
You have something
you can show me?
PAUL: Actually, yes.
Yeah.
So--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's go ahead
and show it to the camera here.
PAUL: So if you
take a look here,
this is actually using live
data from the Guardian, who
graciously offered us their
access feeds to do this.
And so this is a demo app
that I built a few days ago.
And so, as you can see, it's
a fairly smooth navigation.
This is actually a
progressive web app,
so I can navigate in categories.
And then, if I click
on one of those links--
there we go, let's try that--
it opens the actual AMP article.
So this article that you see
right here-- as you can see,
there was a transition
going on here.
And this article
itself is all AMP.
So you have a
progressive web app shell
that just does the navigation.
But then you use AMP as a
data source in your app.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
totally awesome.
Hey, thanks for
showing us that, Paul.
PAUL: Absolutely you're welcome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What is
this going on over here?
It looks cool, and
live, and data.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
It's the I/O transport
tracker, which
this is the second year
we've been running it.
And basically we're--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Show me
what it is up here close.
SPEAKER: There's a
few components to it.
There's an Android app that we
put on to each of the shuttles
running to the different hotels
around the I/O conference.
Those Android apps are
using the Firebase API
to report their
locations as they
travel to each of their stops.
And then this is just a
Google map on a web page
that you subscribe to that same
Firebase database and, funnily
enough, each time the bus moves,
the bus icons on here move.
And so it allows us
to see exactly where
all the buses are.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really awesome.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So this
is us right here, right?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
You can-- some of the buses
you can see are parked there.
And it's all hooked up
with GTFS data, as well.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
So that is the maps
and mobile web tent.
And I think it's time to get
on and see some more stuff here
at Google I/O 2017.
[[MUSIC PLAYING]